hi and welcome to my video series of
mall bio explained in three minutes
where i explain a concept of molecular
biology in three minutes or so if you
haven't yet subscribed the channel
hit that subscribe button right now
today we'll talk about inverse pcr which
is a variant of
pcr that is used to amplify your dna
with only one known sequence inverse
pcr is specially useful for
determination of
insert location let me tell you with the
example for a better understanding
let's say we have a transposon and this
transposon
can jump into any genetic loci right
in the genome so we need to understand
that what is the genomic site where this
transposon
has incorporated itself in order to know
that
we can perform a inverse pcr
let's try to understand it in details
so here is our transposon insertion site
what we know from our knowledge is what
is the sequence of the transposon
but what we don't know is the nearby
region
sequence where the transposon has
incorporated itself
but we have something to begin with
unknown sequence which is the transposon
sequence
now what can be done is a little bit bit
sequence flanking these
unknown sequence can be restriction
digested
and then ligated
now this ligated circular plasmid-like
structure
can be pcr amplified using
a dedicated set of primers
so here you can see these pcr primers
can amplify the whole portion of these
circular plasmid like structure and
ultimately
the pcr amplicons would be generated
now in each pcr amplicon we can have
the sequences the known sequence
flanked by unknown sequences on either
side of it
now if we take the pcr product and then
run this pcr product through a
sequencing machine
we would understand the exact sequence
since we know the sequence of our
transposon we would understand what are
the sequences just
side of this particular transposon and
that would tell us
what is the genetic loci so once we get
the sequence information
we can perform bioinformatic analysis
and blast that particular
sequence into a genomic database and
then it would tell us that which
particular genetic loci
our transposon has uh jumped in or get
got incorporated so this is how inverse
pcr helps us to understand
to find unknown sequences with the help
of one known sequence
and that's all about this video if you
like this video
you can support me on patreon
and also in other applications such as
pim upi
if you like this video give it a quick
thumbs up don't forget to like share and
subscribe thank you